oh I have a question do you think that
as a divorce attorney can cheating be
overcame in a relationship
[Music]
absolutely
on both ends like for men and for women
yes it's harder for men women can get
over cheating a lot easier than men for
men it's very very difficult interesting
um man you know it's kind of it's kind
of interesting how women in this country
through history have been played to be
played out to be the more romantic
couple yeah but you see as a divorce
attorney you know I've been doing this
for 20 years that it's actually the
opposite men are the real Romantics and
so when uh a woman will find out that
her husband is cheating she'll be very
hurt she'll be very disappointed she'll
be very skeptical
um but there's a part in her that name
is like well you know he's a guy and he
makes a lot of money this and that
whereas on the other hand with demand I
mean it's just total devastation yeah
it's the man that was like oh well she
really was beautiful you know I guess
she could have got that extra dick no
that never occurs to a man a man is like
no she loves me I love her I've been
paying the mortgage you know I've been
paying her car I've been getting her
nails done her toes done the eyelashes
how could she cheat on me when I'm
providing so much right do you think
there's a difference like
do rich and poor men get cheated on the
same or no do rich so if you had if you
had like 50 clients like they were
wealthy and 50 you know maybe maybe the
poor ones couldn't really afford you so
you don't know
about 50 clients that are poor like
would you say like they get equally
cheated on
um
it's a great question you know I've
represented so many men who were poor
and they got cheated on and then so many
men who were rich and they got cheated
on
um but also you can have poor men who
are married to this woman and the woman
knows that she's poor and they're not
living right and she'll be faithful to
that man and similarly you can have a
man who's making you know
30 million dollars and the wife is
faithful so I'm sure along some lines
income has something to do with it but
at the end of the day it's going to
depend much more on the personality of
the woman
what do you think the main reason is
that women cheat for like the people
that you see
oh is there like a like a particular
pattern of why they're doing it
I would say it's usually based on their
personality you know if you have a woman
that is more disagreeable and more open
to new experiences uh that's a dangerous
combination for a man to have you know
some some women just like variety right
and men don't normally think about it in
in those terms because men want to think
about love and this and that but men
often forget that that women are humans
like they're just like us right some men
uh are not fit for example for the
institution of marriage because they
love variety way too much and no matter
how much they love that woman and no
matter how many mortgage payments they
pay they are going to cheat and with
women a lot of times it's the same way
now a woman will will rationalize it
will say oh well you weren't
communicating with me enough or or you
know I'm not happy anymore or you're
neglecting me they'll come up with a lot
of reasons but
at the end of the day you know it's very
difficult for a woman for a man to
really ascertain the exact reason why
his particular woman cheated but you
know it's certainly based on personality
it's also based on circumstance if your
wife has a work husband oh
I hope your man has a work wife also
like these work spouses
[Music]
they are so dangerous so so dangerous do
the work spouses
end up like stealing the man ever the
woman vice versa like did will they
leave the relationship for them or they
just get like they're just trouble
I mean a lot of times the work spouses
have spouses oh right so if I if if we
are work spouses you have your spouse at
home I have my spouse at home you know
it's it can be that your spouse finds
out about me but I mean leaving my wife
all right and so it gets very very
complicated but uh you don't typically
see work spouses leaving their spouses
and then coming together you don't you
don't typically do you think they're
just oh sorry I was gonna say I feel
like with work work wives and work
husbands there's more of like an
emotional thing going on like you're at
work you're not going to be [ __ ] and
if you are then okay good luck keeping
your job but uh it's usually like oh so
I had a problem with my wife back home
and then the man comes in and like
confides in you I've had men do that
when I used to work in sales and they'd
complain about their girlfriends it's
like they're looking for that almost
emotional support to feel about it and
vice versa women do the same thing thing
um they were pillow talking not pillow
not sexting or anything like um no
pillow talking meaning
they didn't separate their personal
relationship from what it was that they
was dealing with when they were dealing
with you
more so I feel like when you have like a
work spouse like a lot of the time you
go to that person for the emotional
issues that you're facing in your
relationship so you'll go in and be like
oh she's not having sex with me or oh
he's not treating me this way or
providing in that way so you're going to
them for their [ __ ] you should actually
be going to your husband or wife for
yeah yeah but yeah that's that great but
it doesn't start out that way it always
kind of starts out with like a
friendship you know because usually
these work spouses they've been working
together for months if not years yeah so
a lot of times it doesn't start out I
mean there might be some physical
attraction but this is not how it starts
out so hey do you want to go to lunch
you know oh we've got this uh project
this deadline we might have to work
until eight o'clock and you know month
after month now they're friends and so
of course friends are going to tell each
other about problems that they have
going on at home but because now they're
disclosing private information they
start to build this bond this trust and
now they start to look at each other
with different eyes yeah and so we just
had it can happen very gradually but you
know the bond that they share can be
super all a lot of times especially
pre-pandemic when everybody was working
in the offices you could see you could
really spend more quality time with your
work spouse than your real spouse you
know if you get home at six six thirty
then you got the kids and you got dinner
and then get the kids ready you know you
might not spend any quality time with
your spouse until 8 39 9 o'clock and
then you're in bed trying to wake up
early the next morning whereas you spent
all that time uh Monday through Friday
in the office going to lunch outside of
the office sometimes going to dinner
going for drinks happy hour so you're
spending more quality time with your
work spouse than your real spouse so
it's no surprise that people start
developing attractions uh relationships
uh caring for for the people that they
work with because they spend so much
quality time with those people and it's
it's not just quality time it's like
happy quality time it's Quality quality
time because when you're at home with
your spouse sorry and you have kids
there are issues there are fights that
are coming up but when you're with that
person and you're just like oh I'm happy
like I can just be here I can be me so
you feel like you I feel like it is more
cheating than even having sex with
somebody because you're giving so much
of like that good side of you that the
person at home doesn't get I could
absolutely be the case he had a lot of
emotional disclosure a lot of sharing uh
that can be much more personal than
what's going on in let's say a 13-year
marriage where you know you're here and
she's there and y'all are living in the
same house and raising these kids but
you know after 13 years let's be honest
nobody's feeling butterflies when you
walk in the door right I do
I absolutely do how do you keep that
alive 100 I think that but no I think uh
no no I absolutely do because
it's the fact that I don't spend so much
time up under her
how long y'all been married uh 18 years
so you're saying after 18 years when
your wife walks in the door you feel
better when I walk in the door wow oh
when you walk into her she feels better
lives absolutely oh but because she's
yawning like a lot of stuff
about it like I could be gone
for a week out of town taking care of
business whatever so on and so forth
right like I don't believe that spouses
need to spend an extended amount of time
with each other as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible